I did have a recent realization myself
what kind of kind of pivoting
um I used to [__] really like the
romance genre
what happened
you got married I think so man I think
he's he's tired people the options are
close people probably know this already
but it's like my taste in romance anime
and manga is the most skewed out of any
genre yeah I mean you're like yeah
including isekai yeah you know
um I just it's it's weird because like I
just don't think High School romance
anime or Manga just do it for me anymore
even if it's like a really really well I
mean written romance I feel like half of
these romance shows are from people
who've never had a romance it feels like
it feels like that when I watch it it
feels like they've never had like
they're just like they're like this is
how humans romance I think right right
am I crazy like no no no I definitely
I'm not obviously I'm sure I mean
especially especially the romance manga
that are also haramonga at the same time
are clearly like from people who are
just like who clearly wanted like they
they had a vision of what they wanted
their romance I can't watch anymore yeah
to me it feels like I'm just watching a
dude's OC fantasy and like I I just it
doesn't feel like an actual story
someone's trying to say like yeah it's
obviously a self-indulgent thing I mean
yeah for sure I mean like the Target
demographic for the majority of Harem
anime are like you know ages 13 to 50.
if I'm watching a hentai it's a
different case of course different
different purpose of drinking out of it
but story-wise sorry are you the type of
are you the type of like like what would
you consider as like the peak of romance
anime in in your opinion because
obviously everyone's answers to that are
always different
um Define Peak what do I think is or
what do you think was like the the best
like I think it's actually come out
quite recently if I talk from like a
Critic standpoint which I do think is
the best romance anime especially High
School romance anime to come out in a
very very long time if not ever it's a
kagya kagya season three has been
like in terms of just an anime
adaptation and just how interesting and
how like the route they go down to
portray this romance I think is [__]
incredible and uh and
the payoff you that has happened at the
end of season three was kind of like
worth all of the investment you put into
or like the previous romance leading up
to that I think a lot of thought has
been put into the characters to make
them not just like other because the
thing about romance anime a lot of the
times you see a lot of like
one-dimensional tropes yeah and one
thing like surprised me about kagia
is the fact that
um I forgot the uh author's name [__]
um
written by Satoshi all right something
what the [__] was his name
um [__] yeah the author of Curry or
someone yeah the author of cargo summer
um he's done he's done a [__]
incredible job at characterizing all of
the different characters and actually
giving them more depth than they
initially feel and having them develop
during the course of the show yeah
um and I think I'll give some are on
paper and as a Critic is one of the best
romance anime and manga that has been
made I take domestic girlfriend over
that any day of the week well I would
hope so and that is I don't I just
realized that because I realized
um the most fun I've had like the most
fun I've had with any romance manga in
the past like two years
since the massive girlfriend has ended
it's probably rent a girlfriend oh my
[__] but I think I think I think I
think romance is one of those genres
that is almost more subjective than
comedy at times yeah oh for sure how
every person views romance is so
entirely different and uh I mean it's
it's everyone experiences it in a
completely different way yeah so I think
when you're watching these shows a lot
of them are just trying to like they're
like throwing out their version of
romance and whichever one appeals to the
most in terms of an enjoyment sense yeah
and so it makes sense the domestic
girlfriend would be fun or rent a
girlfriend because it's [__] stupid I
mean I I think I think a big thing uh is
that hey I am in a happy relationship
yeah I want to see another happy
relationship yeah because I I think I
think I'm going to see a [__] car
because I'll be honest I think a big
because I used to [__] love romance
anime and manga so much um I think a big
part of that was just the fact that I
didn't have any in my life you know and
uh this this year I [__] finished my
romance Arc my own life it's done like
I'm like it's no more Romance
and I'm like What's Left okay and seeing
a happy couple get together [__] get
that [__] out of my face man that's
boring [__] give me like the spice maybe
you would relate to a story that's more
about when you're married and the
difficulties of that right like maybe
that'd be more interesting and then
maybe but I think it's just something
that
um I don't know to me like I don't want
something like domestic girlfriend or
rent a girlfriend to happen in my life
obviously [__] [__] no that's all well I
would have had to had an intervention of
that yeah yeah exactly exactly but
reading a story about something like
this stuff happens that if that elicits
a stronger emotional response from me
yeah than just seeing a happy couple
gets it it's just like True Crime for
for you it's just a different spin on
True Crime for you white girls have True
Crime and God has domestic girlfriend
it's a different shape
because it's definitely like [__]
rents a girlfriend I'm never going to
say that it is a good manga okay I'm
never going to say that it is a good
romance but holy [__] I cannot stop
reading it it's entertainment it's and
this is like it's not it's not peak
writing but it to me this is Peak
entertainment because I I read every
chapter I hate every moment of it and
I'm like when's the next every morning
yeah no I I I hate every Mo I hate every
moment of it because I'm like all the
characters make me [__] angry yeah
it's the reality TV of romance it makes
me pissed off I need to see the next
chapter right now and I remember I
remember catching up to rent a
girlfriend and I'm like I need more and
I takes skill though I think is an
author to write something that makes you
hate it but also engaged yeah oh
honestly because there's a very fine
line between hating it and then just
wanting to drop it yeah yeah [__] it no
I'm gonna watch it no no I I I think
that I think that is a very fine line
because there's sometimes you see a bad
show and it's just like this is just bad
I just I just I'm just gonna stop
reading and sometimes you see like a bad
show where you you know you see the
characters they make you angry or like
[__] why why why is this person being
like this or something but there's
something about it that just keeps you
reading even if it's like a hate reads
but but I feel like you say like a bad
show or whatever but like I feel the
moment you're able to elicit any kind of
emotion whether that may be a positive
or A negative emotion towards a
character I think that's immediately a
good show because it's like they managed
to create a character that makes you
[__] feel an emotion right like the
ones like almost all of the series that
I have like dropped manga anime in the
past are the ones that just don't elicit
any kind of [__] emotion like there
is no stimuli there where I'm like these
are all just they're all [__] boring
like it's not even the matter of like I
hate this character or I like this
character like I'm more inclined to sit
around to watch a show of a bunch of
characters I [__] hate than a bunch
of characters I feel nothing towards I
want to disagree with you but I did
watch school days I don't know
that's what I'm saying and that's why I
feel school days gets a lot more hate
that it deserves in that sense because
it's like okay you hated all these
characters but that's a better emotional
response Than A Feeling jumping towards
that character I just helped Joey with
his defense God [__] damn it again I
proved my point once again no y'all
don't listen no because I oh yeah like I
don't want to admit it's good though
because I did catch up to rent a
girlfriend and I was like I need
something else and the what the uh
series I stumbled upon on to like fill
the rent a girlfriend hate hole Yeah uh
or the Spicer I should more call it um
was uh uh quintessential quintuplets
and I remember reading it and I was just
like I mean it's all right
that is definitely the emotion I have as
well yeah I was like this is all right
so if people were like it's all right
um okay question is it is it not
confusing reading it do they not all
look the same no no
um sometimes but like they like
sometimes that's like the part of the
joke right is that one yeah oh that oh I
thought she was someone else yeah
um my problem is that I it's not that
they didn't look the same my problem was
I just couldn't remember all of the
character names
sometimes if her name was see that's
that's a benefit of knowing Japanese
because all the girls names in
quintessential quintuplets have numbers
in their names
foreign
that's so [__] I I completely didn't
notice that yeah okay that's an easy way
to remember holy [__] that's a that's a
life hack right there that would have
made us so much easier yeah because the
oldest is the youngest yeah because I'm
just like if her name isn't Nina I'm
like who
[Music]
that no that's just you tunnel visioning
to the [__] that might be my tunnel
vision tunnel Visionary be like everyone
else is irrelevant give me the secondary
bill I understand God now no but I get
it with good essential quintuples like I
enjoyed reading it but like I I wouldn't
say it's like the goat like I wouldn't
say that or anything like you would
[__] love that [__] no no they do and
I feel it's because like it had just the
right amount for a lot of people it had
like a good amount of you know
wholesomeness like cute like you know
standard you know cut and dry romance
tropes but it also in the second half
especially it had a bunch of spice
thrown into it I mean that's kind of why
I read it because that's what some
people told me and I'm just I'm just
like wait what should I be talking about
well like when you it's kind of like
you're it's kind of like your basic kind
of like love like I guess it's like a
love pentagram up no Pentagon
um
the basic love Pentagon yeah I often
find myself in the love okay but I think
I think in the case with you for example
God like you read you know you read like
rent a girlfriend domestic girlfriend
right and then you went to Quincy that's
like eating a ghost pepper and then
being like all right let me try this
jalapeno no you know it's like it's not
you're kind of downgrading at that point
yeah yeah yeah it's it's like people who
have like Nando's medium and goes oh
this is uh I can't handle this this is
too spicy I'm like this this is spicy
for you what vanilla like and like runs
a girlfriend he gets like NTR right yeah
that sounds way more compelling than
anything I've ever heard from any
romance I want to watch that I want to
see how this man gets cooked yeah it's I
mean I saw it out of context and it was
[__] yeah I saw the image it looked
funny God that made me want to read it
more than anything else I'd heard about
it but but that's what I mean right it's
like even if it's a negative emotion you
feel to look ridiculous emotions yeah a
pretty [__] giant wrist yeah that's
that's like a huge risk and that draws a
lot of people in being like I hate this
I need more yeah it's it's just and I
would argue that's a good show yeah
because I mean I I understand why you
know a lot of people like shows that are
more like traditional romance and stuff
like that
um yeah just I don't know when the last
time I watched one and truly truly
enjoyed one aside from like kagia also
also like nothing ever happens most of
the time in romance shows that's true
and then when it does happen it's always
[__] up and weird it's always like
actually I'm gonna marry a kid and it's
like whoa what like hold on you know
what I mean trouble
considering like we'll have a problem
actually I'm gonna marry a five-year-old
uh that's gonna be what I'm doing all
right uh you're like you do you bro yeah
yeah what no you no no no no no no no no
you do you bro
go to prison bro uh it's like it's just
it's it's yeah I don't know man I
nothing ever happens and when it does
it's it's [__] yeah because at least
with him getting cocked that sounds
funny yeah
why that's hilarious it is [__]
hilarious following this main character
for like uh how many chapters I had this
realization actually the other day I
realized because remember nisekoi yeah
do you remember how do you remember how
it went on for like felt like it went on
for [__] ever oh it was it was the
Avatar Two of romance yeah it was like
the Avatar Two of romance yeah and it
went on like like did you remember
nisekoi yeah I remember the I remember
everyone being annoyed that nothing
happened yeah that nothing happened yeah
and I realized that
um I realized that Nissan koi was like
204 chapters right and I had this
realization that it was long yeah I yeah
it was [__] long I had this
realization that I had read
294 chapters of rent a girlfriend and
it's not even close to being over and
I'm like
just what is this the one piece of
romance anime like I didn't realize it
was it went on for that long because
what I think of long romance anime with
a zero progression I think nisekoi yeah
and I'm like oh yeah that that was the
long show and I realized that rent a
girlfriend is like 100 chapters as well
it's always has already eclipsed that by
a hundred chapters and is still nowhere
near like I mean coming to a club when a
lot of stuff happens you kind of don't
notice the length right yeah if it's
dense and and stuff's always going on
you kind of forgive it yeah yeah yeah
and I I I feel like that that is a lot
of that that is a big problem with a lot
of romance anime nothing happens
that is the textbook example of [__] so
much [__] like at the beginning it's
like all right cool I see this Dynamic
it's kinda cute kind of wholesome all
right let's see what happens yeah and
then you get to like volume eight and
you're just like I can't believe you
guys are still doing the same [__]
because and like another one like
[__] uh you said you caught up to
dress up darling dude yes I was about to
say it like I just I just read volume 10
of my dress up Dolly yeah and I'm just
like this is horring me all over again
bro like it's nothing is oh my this man
has to be gay like they're at this point
don't even bother man like I think
that's the only option
you at this point I just just give up
Mario like it's it ain't worth it bro
yeah it's just and I'm getting scared
like because like the first like four or
five you know and the first like season
of the anime right it was so [__]
cute and wholesome and it's like you you
were like rooting for Mario to be like
yeah [__] go for it bro yeah but like
my God from around like volume eight I'm
just like oh no it's starting to feel
like horror Mia yeah it's there's
there's always this let's say Middle
Point in every romance anime where it's
just like okay they hook you with the
dynamic yeah they have like a little bit
of character development and between
their relationship and stuff and then
there's just like a little bit of just
like nothing yeah and then you just wait
until like something big happens yep and
it's just that middle bit that kills me
every [__] time